the names bond James Bond
I thought since this is a bond review I
would class it up a little bit
Skyfall is the latest Bond film I am a
humungous Bond fan I love bond I've
spent the last two weeks watching every
Bond film I've never been more prepared
for movie in my entire life my favorite
bonds were always the ones that took
bond more seriously and straight away
from all the whole campy jokes you know
not every villain has to be some guy
petting a cat with a giant mountain
fortress who wants to rule the world and
when Martin Campbell directed Daniel
Craig and Casino Royale that movie blew
me away it's one of my all-time favorite
films to this day I love that movie I
think it's better than a Bond film it's
just it's a great movie in its own right
Quantum assault was not as good it was
disappointing I was so pumped for
Skyfall directed by Sam Mendes for
goodness sakes Sam Mendes it has my
favourite director of photography Roger
Deakins Shawshank Redemption this man
has filmed Shawshank Redemption and he's
doing a Bond movie in this movie it's a
darker tale cyberterrorism Javier Bardem
is like this cyber terrorist this hurt
man he's hurt he was betrayed I don't
want to get too into it I won't spoil
anything that's all I'm gonna say M has
secrets that she's holding from bond and
bond is trying to figure out what it is
you seen the trailer that you think he's
dead he comes back now we're in this
world that is so realistic I have not
seen a film with so much over-the-top
elements you know this big franchise
like film treated so seriously
since the Dark Knight and it's
interesting because Sam Mendes said that
the Dark Knight really inspired him in
making this movie he wanted to make a
movie that took something that was well
known to the public like they did with
Batman but made it so realistic and so
serious that you bought it as a film
that you forgot this is a Bond movie and
you viewed it as if it was this really
intense drama with amazing action
sequences it's one of the best bonds
ever made for sure the only competition
it has its Casino Royale this is one of
the best-looking films of the year as I
said Roger Deakins is a cinematographer
for this movie and it looks just
immaculate this film is lit and framed
too
affection it is beautiful this movie
just looks incredible it is a director's
dream this movie Daniel Craig is
excellent as bond he's once again this
wounded cold assassin like man and you
just you can tell that this is the bond
in the Ian Fleming novels he captures
that perfectly but he also has that sly
bit of humor it's nice to see the
character q brought back there's just so
many great little in jokes to the
previous bonds because I've just spent
the past two weeks watching all of them
I can see perfectly how the series
evolved over time how sometimes it would
get at this height of Campina s-- there
was almost Austin Powers like only to be
returned to seriousness by say like when
Timothy Dalton came in was like look a
view to a kill wow that was bad let's
make a living daylights and license to
kill make two really dark Bond films and
he was going to continue making more but
this whole lawsuit thing happened that's
a whole nother video the point is my
favorite bonds are the dark bonds and
this film is dark it's one of those
times we go into a movie and you're like
I know exactly what I'm getting because
of all this stuff I've been given
previously I know the product that's
gonna be handed to me but it's different
from that I'm sure there's gonna be a
lot of Bond fanatics we're like Oh
didn't have all the things I wanted I
didn't like the way the gun barrel
sequence looked or I didn't like the
fact that he didn't say this line or
this line correctly look this is a Bond
film okay because it's stars James Bond
but it is a completely different movie
in its own right from all the films
previous to it all I got to say is you
got to go see Skyfall because it is a
masterclass in excellent dialogue
terrific directing great acting one of
the best Bond villains after you watch
it here it's like wow that would truly
was a ride like that was an adventure
for sure it's a contender possibly even
for best movie of the year so far I have
to really think about it go see Skyfall
please of course
Skyfall gets an A+
thanks a lot for watching this review as
always guys and if you like this and you
can click right here and get stuck my
knife